so good morning I'm Kaabah Kosh news I'm
a faculty member at the Yale School of
Public Health I have the honor of
chairing this distinguished panel our
first panel this morning
I also want to personally thank a
non-pro work she's done over the last
couple of months to getting us here and
I really want to appreciate both opening
remarks from George as well as Katherine
and George by telling us the importance
of coming together getting out of our
silos and captain reminding us that we
all have a contribution to make and to
learn from one another so thank you the
bios of our panelists or in your folks
I'm not going to to read their BIOS you
can see who they are
that the title is for this panel is both
the legal and health challenges facing
refugees and asylum seekers in the
United States we're not going to spend a
lot of time talking about the legal
aspects of it
some of the legal issues facing refugees
and asylum seekers would be addressed by
the second panel which is after the
keynote but for those of you always
wonder the difference between an asylum
seeker refugee you are going to get some
insight about that from the first panel
but be really going to focus on some of
the health issues and we're very
fortunate to have three physicians with
us who be speaking I think after
McKenzie is going to go first talking
about the medical forensic evaluation
for asylum seekers the whole process how
does it work what are they some of the
anticipated challenges in the future
then doctor animal I will talk about
medical care provision of medical care
for Refugees provide some important
background and again talk about some of
the anticipated challenges and changes
going forward and dr. Prabhu will talk
about mental health needs of both asylum
seekers and refugees so without further
ado I'm going to turn it over to dr.
McKenzie Thank You cafe I'm Kate
McKenzie I'm the director of Yale Center
for
medicine and I'm going to take a few
minutes a day to talk about medical
evaluations of asylum seekers and then
some of the anticipated challenges that
we have foreseen with the new
administration I start with this slide
and listening to speakers who've already
spoken to talk about how there is a
humanitarian impulse to provide refuge
and safety to asylum seekers and this
has been an impulse that is basic to our
humanity over thousands of years in fact
each year tens of thousands of people
from around the world seek refuge
humanitarian relief from deportation so
that they can rebuild their lives in the
United States this vulnerable group
includes survivors of torture domestic
abuse trafficking and other forms of
persecution many have suffered
unimaginable physical and psychological
torture in their countries of origin
even if they can afford an attorney they
face the daunting task of providing
detailed independently corroborated
evidence of harm as required by the
government if they're sent back to their
countries of origin they face further
persecution even death medical
evaluations of asylum seekers
significantly increase the likelihood
that asylum will be granted our group at
the medical school Yale Center for
silent medicine is comprised of faculty
members students fellows residents and
what we try to do is use a physician's
unique expertise to give asylum seekers
a chance for a new life free of fear
just going to take a couple minutes to
talk about asylum applicant we saw a
couple years ago in our Center to give
you kind of the context of the work that
we do this man came from the Democratic
Republic of the Congo and lived under a
very repressive autocratic government
and he did what so many of us do
especially in the last few months he
decided to protest against his
government he became a member of an
opposition political party and one day
they had a peaceful protest and
government officials then gathered at
the protest site and arrested him and
many other of the protesters and what it
resulted in was for him five days of
detention interrogation and torture he
was taking an interrogation room a
couple times a day his life was
threatened he was beaten severely he was
cut he was burned it was so
overwhelmingly painful traumatic he was
filled with fear as soon as that ended
he realized he had to leave the DRC and
he decided to come to United States to
seek refuge to seek shelter from his
persecution he was able to find an
attorney here in Connecticut and when
talking to his attorney and talking
about his torture he was able to tell
the attorney what had happened and the
attorney realized he had some physical
scars and mental scars as well so we
have already read about his recount of
persecution his account of persecution
we then live here in ourselves and then
we perform a physical exam so that's
what we did with mr. eighty we examined
him and we saw the scars of the physical
torture he had experienced he showed us
on his leg a scar from being cut with a
bayonet
he showed us also scars on his foot
where he was burned so we use
international guidelines then to gather
that information in history and physical
exam we documented on a body diagram and
with photographs as you saw and then we
create a medical legal affidavit which
we provide to his attorney and that
medical legal affidavit becomes part of
his asylum claim his asylum appeal and
in fact together with the information
that we gathered and which we provided
to his attorney he was granted asylum so
that kind of encapsulates in a very
brief way the work that we do medical
evaluations of asylum seekers and in
fact a recent study has shown that
people who are able to have medical
evaluations as part of their asylum
appeal are almost three times more
likely to be granted asylum so all of us
in the last few months have been living
in a state of uncertainty about where
our country is going in many regards I
think we can understand that but when
you think of the life and the experience
of an asylum seeker it's so tenuous to
begin with there in legal limbo their
families are usually back where they
came from they're just living in
uncertainty so superimpose that on the
setting up on our political setting at
this time and the uncertainty has just
compounded so I can't tell you how the
experience of asylum seekers is going to
change in the next four years but we can
certainly say that it's likely to change
significantly so I'm not an attorney but
I understand a little bit about the
legal background and certainly there's
attorneys here who want to clarify a
little bit feel for you to speak up but
when someone initially appeals for
asylum speaks with an immigration
official and says I'd like to claim
asylum they have to go through what's
called a credible fear test to show that
there's a likelihood they will be
persecuted
they're returned to their home country
and there's certainly indications that
the bar will be raised which that sort
of credible fear test there's some
subjectivity to it is it going to be
much more difficult for people at the
initial time when they want to appeal
for asylum will be given the chance to
do so we certainly anticipate that the
asylum process which actually can be
many years long sometimes it's just a
year but it's certainly going to be a
year to a tree when it actually occurs
that the immigration officials will be
much more adversarial certainly there is
indication that that might be the case
given various policies that President
Trump has proposed as well as what we've
heard in is campaign rhetoric greater
need for documentation that's where we
come in we certainly try to provide
objective evidence that there has been
persecution and we anticipate that
documentation will become even more
important we've already seen that
detention policies are going to be much
stricter and one part of that is for
example on the southern border as
families are often coming across the
border
there's indication they may be separated
which compounds the stress and the fear
that they already have imagine being
separated from your children increased
time in detention that certainly might
happen as well and there certainly is
indication that fewer people will even
come to the United States this country
that we all believe should be a beacon
of hope for those people who have been
persecuted many people will decide it's
not even worth it to come to the United
States the policies are so uncertain and
the official policy of our government is
so hostile so these are some ideas of
what we might be facing in the next
almost four years so finally just to
summarize when we perform medical
evaluations of asylum seekers we follow
international guidelines to determine
consistency of history and examination
in order to determine the likelihood of
human rights violations and as
physicians for human rights one of our
strong partners stated so closely so
well we
work at the intersection of medicine
forensic science and human rights thank
you good morning everyone
as OSHA briefly introduced me I am
faculty in the School of Medicine and
clinically I practice both internal
medicine and psychiatry purpose which
skills come in very useful for me in the
clinical care of refugees you'll be
hearing next from my approval who's my
colleague within psychiatry who helps me
perform some of those psychiatric
evaluations as you probably realized by
this time all of us on this panel are
talking about the work we do for
Refugees and asylum seekers here you
know within this within the country and
you'll be hearing a range of experts but
people both here and abroad during the
course of the day but dr. Mackenzie as
she mentioned she evaluates asylum
seekers here what I do here is I provide
clinical care for refugees who are
already here and just very quickly the
legal difference is just that refugees
are here because they've been legally
accepted as a refugee by the United
Nations and then they've been welcomed
by the United States for entry into the
country which is a little bit different
from the asylum seekers that dr.
Mackenzie evaluates because they're here
seeking asylum they're not yet legally
recognized as refugees they're fighting
for that status but as far as how goes I
mean they're almost similar in terms of
the health conditions that we might be
seeing and we might be dealing with so
many of you here or at least some of you
have heard me talk about just the health
of refugees is going to be very brief
because this is a panel discussion and
we want to invite questions I'm just
going to say briefly what we see and
what we do in clinic but for those of
you who may not know
I just I know there's a lot of words
here but this is just a pictorial
representation of what a refugee goes
through once you know there once the
United Nations actually accepts them as
a refugee and then they go through this
whole process before they actually get
resettle into a country what happens is
usually a refugee crosses their
country's borders because they're
fleeing and then they're in this in
limbo in a secondary country and that's
when they're going through this process
and some of them get resettled and
unfortunately it's a very very very
small fraction of refugees in the world
that actually get resettle to a third
country including the United States I
mean the u.s. is one of several
countries so there's there's multiple
steps and that this can take anywhere
from a year and a half to four years or
more some of our refugees have been in
limbo for for a decade or two I just
want to point out just in relation to
health number five on this slide is
actually talking about medical screening
that refugees undergo overseas you may
have heard from other people that
refugees are actually one of the migrant
groups that are very very heavily vetted
security-wise
but actually medical screening also
they're more better than most other
actually on any other migrant groups in
terms of just cleaning for health
conditions so they are not coming in
with communicable diseases and they're
not in any way a health hazard to to
people that are already here so this is
just again just a colorful pictorial way
of showing they're within the US and
this is a little bit older this is still
2015 and you can see the the darkest
blue are the states that actually are
getting the highest number of refugees
the very light blue are the ones that
are getting the least amount of refugees
and Connecticut is sort of on the lower
end not because I mean as you know
generally the
and you know generally Connecticut has
been welcoming of refugees it's just
because of the size of the state larger
states tend to get you know more number
of refugees typically and there's also
been lots of changes in numbers in the
last year and a half simply because of a
lot of things that have been happening
politically so what we do here is we
partner as as the University and as the
ilium and hospital with Iris which is
the local resettlement agency integrated
refugee and immigrant services and
actually I think the health coordinator
from there just walked in she's she's
just looking in so we've been in
partnership with them for many years we
actually a group of trainees actually at
the hospital started the clinic because
we wanted to have a dedicated clinic to
provide clinical care and dr. Rustica
actually has been one of the guiding
mentors of the clinic he's going to be
on a panel later today so our purpose is
to establish these refugees within our
healthcare system once they come in and
they're there is also actually a
mandated screening that they have to
undergo that the Department of State
does require but the main purpose of our
screening really is to establish them
within healthcare they may or may not
have you know had good health care on
their way here that there's varying
levels depending on on their route so
they get a screening overseas then they
get a screening with us and they get
longitudinal care and within our
partnership as how we structured it is
all the refugees within the greater nee
New Haven area essentially come through
the Yale New Haven Hospital system so
just talking about you know maybe
potential changes we might see well the
most obvious changes obviously we going
to see your number potentially I mean we
don't know this is a changing landscape
but what does that mean for us I mean
what it really means for the refugees
who'd come here is that they might be
delayed somewhere I mean they might be
in
Jordan Lebanon Egypt wherever it may be
you know potentially with health
conditions that they don't have the
resources to address appropriately so
it's there's a delay in care and just
anecdotally we know people with diabetes
who you know maybe haven't been able to
get insulin all the time and who had
fluctuating levels of care we see that
as as a population I mean I can say
delay in care is it's not good I mean
it's hard to encapsulate this in numbers
but just just from clinical experience I
can say that that's you know definitely
detrimental and also we've seen on the
people who are already here
sometimes they're separated for families
they've already come here they've been
accepted and they've been waiting for
the families and maybe now with you know
more restrictions more stringent
criteria maybe the families won't make
it so you know we've definitely seen
again anecdotally people you know maybe
having to go to the hospital especially
in the initial days of the new
administration and there was a lot of
changes and then you know there was this
potential ban on entry of refugees we
definitely did see people in distress
people who are already here even though
you know David and Safety and also I
think to some extent they did feel a
little unsettled because they were not
sure how welcome they were anymore
even though the country had you know
quote unquote welcome them as a refugee
and then I think the last thing which is
also not in any way the least important
is basically what another potential
thing that might change is you know the
Affordable Health Care Act we don't know
where it's going but if things do change
as it's going to affect all Americans
it's going to effects refugees too
because as things stand now they do they
are eligible for medical assistance for
the first eight months which is
essentially sort of the state each
state's in state insurance Medicaid
program which is what makes it possible
for them to access healthcare within the
first several months and
happens after that is usually they are
eligible like all other Americans to buy
insurance from marketplace and you know
because of their low income which is
true for all of them in the first few
years they are then able to access a lot
of the benefits available for low-income
people and so all of this might change
and generally with fewer resources in a
few less funding we might also have
difficulty with accessing additional
resources like interpreters for example
that's a big challenge as it is for us
because those of you who are practicing
physicians will know that unfortunately
a lot of health care is still based on
reimbursement and revenue and when we
actually need to spend more time and
resources on engaging interpreter
services in the clinic that's usually
not conducive for clinics financially
and that that that's a whole other topic
in itself but that's one of the
challenges we find when we are referring
refugees elsewhere for care we are we
lucky with the nearly human Hospital to
actually have a lot of those resources
so that's another thing that might be
indirectly affected with changing
landscape of healthcare so I'm going to
actually stop there and then after the
last speaker if you have more specific
questions about what I said we can talk
more good morning everybody thank you so
much for coming my name is Maya Prabhu
I'm one of Psychiatry attendings in the
refugee clinic I work with ani and Kate
less frequently do I see Kate this
pleasure to see her here and I wanted to
speak a little bit about the mental
health needs I'm going to focus
primarily on resettled refugees so I'm
happy to answer questions on the silence
seekers and I'll try to draw
distinctions and differences as they
come up in the presentation so this
audience will be aware that of course
mental refugees have a variety of
experience a variety of traumas or
de-stresses in their life which can lead
to mental health concerns I think we're
probably most familiar with what I call
the previous settlement stresses the
challenges or the situations or the
experiences that led people to leave
their country often in the middle of the
night whether it was the experience of
being detained whether it's the
experience of being experiencing
violence or observing violence
harassment or deprivation whatever those
cases might have been people are
familiar with it and of course those are
often the primary traumas which people
then present to our clinic with mental
health symptoms for however I wanted to
emphasize that refugees actually
experience layers of trauma at different
stages in the process of leaving their
home country to arriving in the United
States so the experience of flight
itself is deeply traumatizing and
distressing they may have had to leave
family members behind they may have had
to make choices about what they're going
to bring they certainly do they will may
have had to travel over land or over sea
you've seen those boats capsizing the
Mediterranean and people may have seen
death or become close to death
themselves we know that flight itself is
our present risk factors for sexual
trafficking for sexual assault again for
physical assault not just for women but
for children and men as well and even
being approximate to those experiences
can be very distressing for the people
who actually make it over so that's the
second layer of distress we've talked a
little bit about the legal process there
is not a refugee I've spoken to or a
refugee with a legal team that I've
worked with and I see that our
representative from Iraq is there and he
will talk about that experience in more
detail but the experience of going for
the resettlement process is when you
systematically described as traumatizing
and distressing interrogatory and very
often hostile whether or not that scene
10 to the adjudicators who are hearing
their cases
imagine having fled a horrible situation
and now being asked to recount the story
again and again and again with the
presumption that you are telling a lie
and it's not deny that there are
security concerns and fraud concerns but
for the many the majority of individuals
who I have seen who have fled under with
the best of intentions of survival and
to have to recount have their
credibility being challenged is really
deeply humility
and traumatizing and often they present
that is their most significant event
rather than the actual events which
cause them to flee in the first place
and then once they get here
acculturation there are you know the
thought of being in America and being
safe consisting refugees for a long
period of time but once they get here
they very quickly realize the life is
not easy in the United States they have
to get a job often that will be a
minimum-wage job their issues around
English it's not as good as they thought
it would be many of experienced are
experiencing racism or hostility based
on their religion for the first time in
their life and they realize that life is
truly just beginning and often we see a
depression setting in after three or
four months if people realize the extent
to which they'll have to rebuild their
lives and so when they come to the
refugee clinic they will often present
with a variety of symptoms which can be
rather protein can be really challenging
for us to sort out anxiety absolutely in
a variety of ways patients rarely
present with depression I'm feeling
depressed or I have PTSD rather they'll
often present with headaches or pain or
general distress and it's our challenge
to try to put a diagnosis on it for the
purpose of treatment but also try to
find a way to manage that distress
there's a lot that can be said about the
what we call the cultural expressions or
idioms of distress and I think those are
very relevant particularly when you're
doing longitudinal care for a patient
the subtle ways in which a patient may
signal to you that they are experiencing
something but I actually found in the
screening process that is by listening
carefully patients from abroad present
the same kinds of symptoms that patients
here do them and it's not that difficult
I think over time to make a diagnosis of
PTSD or depression which is kind of
reassuring it reminds you of the
universality of human experience
including the University of human
biology in the presentation of mental
illness so patients will describe say
depression I'm so tired I can't get out
of bed I'm so sad but the people I've
left be home and the symptoms related to
PTSD I don't like to leave the house the
door slams and I jump and I hear a sound
outside and I want to hide on the floor
these are symptoms that a lot of our
trainees are very anxious about missing
cultural expressions but in fact
I think they have the skills to
recognize fairly universal symptoms I
wanted to draw a little bit of attention
to the significant history of sexual
assault that our patients experienced
both men and women and I think this is
something we really had to open her eyes
to over time
aside from B sometimes these sexual
assaults they might have experienced
which might be their index event or
there are other things that we have
learned over time detention itself both
for men and women is very much a risk
factor for sexual assault not only
having experienced it but having
witnessed it or being forced to
participate in it in others
flight is clearly a risk factor for
women and we've learned that the assault
can happen not often just by strangers
but their families can be colluding in
it as well
so it took me a while to clue into this
case a woman who basically signaled to
me
my husband made me visit his friends
every night and I didn't like them and
over time I realized that her husband
was prostituting her in order to get
money for their trip and this was deeply
distressing and of course some conflicts
even more than others rape is well known
as having been used as a weapon of war
and when I began this work I think I
felt like it was part of my
responsibility to explore all that
trauma and get the details of it in the
kind of model that we use here which is
Chris Tarsus is necessary in order to
resolve it but I think over time we've
learned that merely hearing it
acknowledging it even it's an oblique
way I understand what happened I am so
sorry that it happened to you many other
women have gone through that too can be
the beginning of a useful rapport and
hopefully the beginning of a healing
relationship over time we have learned
that there's no single best way to treat
our refugees you know I think we began
by having visions of a clinic that would
be there and present for people for 18
months or two years in which refugees
would be able to come and see it on a
weekly basis and I would get wraparound
care turns out this may not be actually
what they want and it's the whole
experience has been a reminder in
cultural humility and listening to the
patients rather we've learned that at
the beginning certainly after
resettlement there's intense need for
stabilization patients come to us saying
please help me sleep so that I can get
to work and go to English class and
mr. sack success in America and let me
tell you there is no better way to be a
hero to a patient than missing them get
to sleep so that the nightmare is
resolved and they can stay awake in
English class the next day so I think I
think how we sometimes think about it is
that the first three months can be a
period of stabilization help them
resolve the pain and help them connect
with their primary care doctors work
closely to resolve the most acute
de-stresses and then we try to say we'd
like to be open for you should you want
to come back and that longer-term
therapy or treatment or trauma focused
work we keep the door open for them and
I think there's been a lot of discussion
amongst medical providers but why that
is what kind of failure of outreach have
we have redone why can't we bring them
in therapy well it's not true that we've
failed to engage refugees as a whole
they're tremendous resource issues which
we'll talk about in a sec in a second
but I note my colleague Michelle Silva
sitting in the audience who's had much
better success by doing groups that are
focused around less obviously mental
health focused issues in the community
so she works with in schools with kids
after school and she's able to do work
there which is focused in the
cultivation and management and effect
management or she's done parenting
groups at the refugee center which bring
people together around topics that are
familiar that are not necessarily about
the trauma that they've been to which
provide opportunities for solidarity
we've used a variety of particular of
models many of them have been successful
I think the biggest thing is being able
to tell refugees that there are ways
that we can help you when you are ready
my colleague Anya has talked about
barriers to care there are so many so
we've been very lucky to have received
requests from physicians in the
community saying we'd love to take on
refugees but as Ani said this is not an
easy task
insurance is a barrier to care
translation is a huge barrier to care
most physicians can't afford to pay for
an agency interpreter and it's not
reimbursed in fact we had a wonderful
social worker therapist who paid out of
pocket for a therapist for it for a
translator for two years for one of her
patients until that arrangement just no
longer worked
we know that having refugees especially
really resettled refugees is time
intensive and very disruptive for
clinics it may not appear on time they
may appear late it may appear with their
entire family and the mother-in-law and
so managing refugees is managing an
entire family and it can be very
challenging for the flow of the busy
clinic lots of physicians and I
apologize I mean I tend to default to
the word physicians but we know that
there are providers a variety of
backgrounds cover with refugees in the
communities and we're grateful actually
by the huge multidisciplinary interest
that we've had in this population we
know that providers are very concerned
about cultural competence they don't
know they don't want to break refugees
anymore and so they don't know if they
can manage the cultural issues there's
an issue of compassion fatigue if you
get designated as a provider if you're
able to take on an arabic-speaking
patient before you know it every
arabic-speaking patient in the state is
going to be coming your way and that's
great except that that is hard for a
single provider to feel like they're
responsible for the health care of an
entire community and that's
understandable too and I would be remiss
if I didn't mention this which is
countertransference or dis distress so
as I have absolutely heard from clinics
and from mental health workers and mine
staff but why are we taking on these
people you know just because we're in
the health profession doesn't mean that
everyone is open to all the patients
that may come through their doors and
I've heard individuals say why are we
here providing health care to foreigners
when we can't even provide for basic
health care of our own people in a time
of budget cutbacks and I say my night
over time I've realized that's an
understandable response by people
because everyone is trying to do more
with less for more people and I feel
like if we had a better healthcare
system but actually provided
comprehensiveness and universality of
access to everyone not just refugees
we'd be in a better position to serve
all of our patients including refugees
I'd like to note that as a whole our
refugees are interesting diverse
delightful to engage with they are
incredibly resilient and I hope we
talked about that word over the course
of the day we know that we're seeing the
people who have survived the most
navigate their way here using
individuals who don't want to be sick
they don't want to be seeing the doctor
they're not flooding our emergency room
they're not flooding the crisis units
they want to get better so they can be a
success in America and mostly they will
be they have low rates of substances
they have low rates of criminal justice
involvement and as a whole they're very
motivated to do well I wanted to end on
a note I don't know if any of you saw
this article I encourage you to read it
from The New Yorker a few weeks ago is
this beautifully written as all things
are in The New Yorker and then it talks
about phenomena in Sweden refugee
children who fall into a deep sleep a
uniquely Swedish phenomenon related to
their legal status and in this Swedish
consensus report that's discussed in the
article the serve diagnosis for this is
that the psychological distress that
these individuals are facing is related
to the feelings of insecurity and if
only we could create some space for
stability for individuals and that is
that is often what it's needed being
told that they can stay in Sweden is
what's needed to resolve this and I
bring this up because fundamentally what
I think our work is about is about
creating a safe space for our
individuals to know that they've got
this place where they can heal over time
and at their pace and I also think it's
about creating solidarity so I
understand that much of the day will be
focused on how to connect with refugees
around the world as well as here but for
me I could not do this work if it wasn't
for the Solidarity that I experienced
with my colleagues with my colleague ani
who I work with on Wednesdays with the
folks in the resettlement agencies who I
here with Steve and his colleagues from
from I wrap solidarity goes always not
just to worry with the refugees but with
our colleagues as well if the only
antidote to very difficult work in a
time I think of some political despair
so I am delighted to see you here and I
look forward to conversations and the
Solidarity that I hope we create thank
you
[Applause]
thank you so much for three very
thoughtful and concise presentation so
we wanted to have a discussion around
advocacy and how do we advocate for our
patients but I think before we do that I
want to open it up and give you a chance
to ask questions from our panelists we
do have a bit of a time in about 20
minutes
yeah sure yeah is there is that I think
is a microphone clone of you she loves
your mom turns green yeah as an advocate
for Refugees working with them day by
day week by week it's my impression that
everyone needs some sort of we don't
want to call it mental health because I
turns people off but if people don't
come to seeking psychiatric care or
mental health care or come to providers
talking about how they can't sleep and
and that and their worries and why they
can't sleep that almost everybody has
that problem and that there should be
some universal it seems to me and I
don't really know about all the programs
that happen but I think the one and with
the parents and the school children
sounds really wonderful and that
everyone should have that opportunity so
that refugees don't have to explicitly
individually seek the care but we
providers should assume that there's
going to be a need for some support for
everyone maybe there's I'd you name for
that I do think that yes I think that
there should be a universal offering of
care maybe in groups I'm not sure if you
don't mind could you just introduce
yourself too
my name is Carol Koenig I'm a family
nurse practitioner I'm retired and have
been a professor at Yale at the School
of Nursing and right now I'm working
through J Carr and iris with in helping
individual refugees a couple of
questions and then they have you guys
address it living it maybe two more
Marsha I'm stink thank you I sometimes
think it's just you know Yale and what
you're doing through the hospital and
through iris and I wrap I mean it
refugees who end up here in a way in a
privileged position and so I was
wondering if you've given us these
wonderful presentations about what
you're doing is that replicated in other
parts of the country you know is it sort
of unique to this particular community
can you talk about the sort of
nationwide scope of Asylum medicine
refugee medicine and so forth to give a
little broader sort of framework for it
please
hi I'm Christina Castellani I'm with the
International Institute of Connecticut
were based out of Bridgeport we work
with refugees and immigrants I
specifically work with refugees and
asylum seekers with our survivors of
torture program so I was really inspired
to hear from dr. Kate McKenzie about her
work with survivors of torture but one
of the things that we're always saying
is we have our clients come in and they
really you know they want to hit the
ground running like like it was
mentioned you know I really want to get
those jobs and just move forward with
their lives starting in America but
there is an obvious need for mental
health but there's also huge stigma and
taboo so I I would like to hear a little
bit about how you approach that we've
had some of our clients talk about how
you know therapy is stealing stealing
their soul or sucking their souls so you
know there's a lot of barriers for them
as well as for their children so I I'd
be curious to hear someone start a
little bit about how to do the outreach
so I think as a whole primary care
providers have gotten better and are
seeking education and training about
identifying the mental health issues
that refugees will experience whether or
not they explicitly flag them in fact we
get many referrals for mental health
care and then it's very challenging
often refugees themselves do not want to
come and see a psychiatrist in fact my
first question is were you aware that
you're seeing a psychiatrist today and
do you really want to speak to me and
then there's the larger question and I
think there is stigma there are issues
of time I think there is the absurd
fragmentation of our health care system
I know what we hear again and again is
why do I need to see one doctor from my
eye and another from my shoulder and
then another person for mental health
and I can only come up Wednesdays at 6
o'clock that I have other things I mean
I think you don't need to be a refugee
to find our current system overwhelming
and the text messages that they get for
reinder appointments can be daunting so
I think there are a lot of barriers just
to getting into the system
and once they get even if they can
overcome the stigma we absolutely have
challenges around resources we don't
always have people available to do
therapy and our numbers have ebbed and
flowed over the years and by the time we
have somebody the patient may have moved
on or have moved out of state or be busy
with the job and it families it would be
great if we could have something that
was more flexible and open so that as
needed because this actually reflects
people's lives right they may need
intense their help at one time have a
period of stability get rid by an event
and need to come back in and we don't do
that well for most people and it's
particularly challenging when there's
translation and you know for Refugees so
it may well be better if it ends up
being situated in the community as
Michelle is doing but you're identifying
very real barriers as it turns out we do
have I've been told at an unusual model
with iris our resettlement agency that
what we do is very rare and I think Ani
can talk a little bit more about the
national models for this so yeah that's
responding a little bit to your question
when mainly to you move out so there's
actually a there's actually a group of
healthcare providers of disciplines
actually resettlement coordinators are
also part of this we actually now have a
society of refugee health care providers
and that's you know what four or five
hundred people every year actually
assembled together to talk about it
happens once a year in June to talk
about just various programs they're
doing how we can improve health care you
know both research clinical reasons and
all sorts of issues but the point is
just that there are many people doing
this across the country I think each
model is very different as a sort of an
academic academic Community Partnership
that's not that common though there's a
few actually there's a group in
Minnesota they've had the I think they
call it the center for international
health and they are actually sort of the
forerunners of refugee especially the
health part of it and there's other
groups and again it's very very variable
in
terms of halal its structured but sort
of the answer is yes there's a lot
happening and it's just taken various
faiths and from the shapes and forms and
some are more structured than others and
this one's to your question about the
Sigma in general I mean that's one of
the good things that we are able to do
here because we see them in a primary
care setting in the beginning and it so
happens that I'm also a psychiatrist and
so we do some sort of screening
initially but even if I wasn't at the
Curtis I mean the the general refugee
guidelines also say to really do that
screening within the primary care center
and not to send everybody you know for a
mental health referral saying you know
you really need to see a psychiatrist
you know just because of the trauma we
face we don't do that we sort of screen
them in that very somewhat safe primary
care setting and then we really you know
sort of triage them into different
levels I mean mental health or mental
illness is such a nebulous thing you
know how do you when do you classify
that somebody's really suffering from
something or not you see various levels
of distress so it's only when we feel
the Sun somewhere is seriously impaired
from there you know whatever they're
going through that we didn't really seek
to send them to specialized mental
health evaluation and treatment and
usually in those cases people are fairly
amenable and willing I think for
treatment because they don't that much
distress but it's a whole group of
people sort of in the middle who are
definitely in distress but maybe it's
not that impeding maybe they're still
sort of able to work do some of the
daily things and they try to create
other things for them we keep going back
to Mitchell who has actually done some
groups in the community for parents and
mothers and children and then we've
actually had some other trainings go and
do some health literacy classes that is
one of them wasn't stress management so
it was very non-threatening environment
and actually one of the social workers
within itis is actually trying to set up
her own little sort of little therapy
you know morning for Refugees which
there are other complications within
that you know he/she a case manager is
she a therapist for a particular person
so that's a whole other issue but that
we have try to incorporate other things
sort of
then the larger community and a lot of
things we do like I'm I'm dad is a
social worker she does is swing groups
gardening groups here I mean those are
all we don't call that necessarily
mental health treatment but they're all
part of supporting them so so I guess
that's just various things we try to do
with the within the limited resources we
have okay I've been fortunate to partner
with iris and lessons here and that's my
and Ani have mentioned because it's such
an enthusiastic I think an energetic
group of people and most of my work has
concentrated in in the community has
been mentioned and really around
education and normalizing the experience
of being displaced in a new setting what
does that mean as a I'm a clinical
psychologist by training mainly working
for many years with Central American
immigrants and many of the distress and
a culture of stressors that come with
that community or that we've seen is not
unlike much of the distress experience
where the refugees in the New Haven area
so much of my work has been again led by
iris and the collaboration that's
already there working with children and
their after-school program creating
relationships normalizing that being in
a new school in a new setting is
difficult and with the parents again
that the stress of being in a new place
what does it mean to be a parent in the
United States how do I not lose my child
to this new system and some of our
conversations with Maya nani have been
around us with mentioned the
universality that much of their distress
is not unlike what we see here and when
you speak to any parent or any child in
addition of course of it to the context
that they're in but i think that sums up
a lid i don't want to take too much time
you're not oh sorry no you ready my
experience living in this community of
new haven is that we are so uniquely
fortunate between this outstanding
resettlement refugee resettlement agency
of ira
which is phenomenal and the programs
that we have as well as community at
Yale I don't think that this sort of
cohesive outstanding set of programs is
replicated very many places in the
country of course New York you have
everything in Boston as well maybe Los
Angeles but we really have a model here
and and it's somewhat serendipitous how
everything has come together now I think
that Ani talked about a conference will
be going to in do the North American
refugee health healthcare conference
that's where people who do the work that
we do get together and it's a good
community as well it's from those
international organizations that we see
how unique New Haven is and finally I
just want to throw one thing out here
which is again unique to our community
but I'm not sure if any of you read the
times that we can review every Sunday
and if you've noted that a graphic novel
that's been going on do you know what
I'm talking about so just as a little
coincidence the yeah Jake Alpert lives
in New Haven as does Michael Sloan so
there's something that's beyond just the
institutions that we have in New Haven
that makes it a really special place and
I'm sorry I thought about that because
of what Michelle said and the story of
the family and the kids going to school
could you tell me the acronym jr. I
founded for native Jake are with a
Jewish community alive virus and we are
the sponsor of that family in the car
system Oh
and Carol works with us as well I think
what I'm hearing is you know I'm a part
of being an exemption co-sponsorship
so there's groups across the state now
sponsoring refugees we've been intense
time with them we learn for what to do
with that and so it seems to me many
times I've said to Iris we you know
co-sponsors need support so if we could
have a workshop where we can come
together and we can deal with what what
do I do when the family says to me my
kids not sleeping he won't go into the
kitchen at night he won't go to the
bathroom by himself I told the school
they're not doing anything I mean we
carried this pain around with us because
we don't know how to help them
hi Dennis Wang first year medical
student have the pleasure to work with
dr. McKenzie and some of the panelists
up there I was I know that iris likes to
talk about the co-sponsorship model as
certainly something that has drastically
increased the capacity of iris to be
able to resettle refugees I think they
doubled from 2015 to 2016 but I've also
had discussions with people about you
know co-sponsorship groups needing more
support things that co-sponsorship
groups do very well things that you know
potentially there could be some
improvement on and I also know that
co-sponsorship is something that Canada
does a little bit so I was wondering if
any of you could talk sort of more
broadly about co-sponsorship where it
fits in what it does well where there
could be some improvement I have lived
in Yerevan for over 12 years
and most of my friends family members
are refugees from Ethiopia Eritrea and
Somalia and South Sudan
I'm ever admit I'm trying to get little
port right now because there is no
mention of what refugees themselves or
that sufferers themselves to do about
all these stressors problems there is
nothing I heard so far it is definitely
I know I I read closely I have worked
with them of other issues but the most
resilient thing about refugees
especially speaking of the communities
the Family Center in New Haven is just
there their own strength
they have associations if you have an
area in a community around here great
early wave New Haven and Hartford in
also beautiful to Waterbury but their
associations are not even registered or
have no office they tend to be more
informal just as they've wanted and you
know they come together on burials or
when hundred problems occur and all that
and some sort of appreciation to that in
just a reach out a mention including
from meetings like this will be will
will take a long way thanks question
reminding us that the refugees have
their own communities and they draw a
lot of support from those so let me just
turn it over and I know we have iris
representative as well if they want to
talk about the community code
sponsorship question but anybody wants
to a couple of things let me begin with
the co-sponsorship question yes I
actually think that any co-sponsorship
group would benefit from some training
and how to manage and
by mental health issues and how to
manage their own stress vicarious trauma
and compassion compete because I think
is a better view whether and how to
bring mental health and physicians on
board at the very beginning so that
co-sponsorship groups not in position of
having to find help after a situation
has arisen because because that's always
frantic and over the last year ani and I
have tried to reach out to other
hospitals community clinics places where
refugees ought to be getting their care
to try to do work on that that has
actually turned out to be very
challenging because the clinics have
their own barriers to care often
beginning around translation we can't
take on these patients because of their
insurance we can't take on these
patients because of translation and so
then patients get shunted back to Yale
and I use the word shunted because I
don't think that if anyone is traveling
an hour and a half for care that's great
care or accessible care so that's a
little bit about some of the weaknesses
of the co-sponsorship model but yes it
has been done I think one of the reasons
why Canada does it better in a certain
way I'm Canadian so by the way is is I
do think there is a universality of
access to social services including
healthcare that just takes a huge issue
off the table a huge case management
piece off the table from the beginning I
agree with you we didn't talk about the
refugee experience from the position of
recently resettled refugees partially
because it feels a bit presumptuous but
also because we don't know that much
about it
and we need to find a way to incorporate
that in a more systematic way into work
that we do
I believe actually one of the challenges
you don't get those conversations and to
hear those details when you're coming
into it on the outside and so how do we
glean that information in a way that's
unvarnished and truths that we can learn
from it so maybe we'll see all right
come with me I don't want to put you on
this I'm going to add a box of
co-sponsorship model but just yeah many
anecdotally I can just add on to what
Maya said about being great I think I
can just speak loudly I mean just I
think tend to get a lot of individual
support you know from co-sponsorship
groups but at the same time sometimes we
feel maybe they haven't had that much
experience in navigating some of the
health challenges and addressing some of
the immediate health issues because for
instance our health coordinators
partners at iris have done this for
years and they've worked with us so they
have more they sort of know the next
steps you know when somebody comes to
them for that so totally and I totally
agree about doing workshops
I mean we've started this annual
healthcare conference now we did that
twice but it's very short we have we
really have to expand that and include
different groups and include really
various levels of of healthcare which
which are hoping to do over time but
sorry Leslie I don't know if you had
I'll just introduce myself and Leslie
I'm the health promoter and I work with
a small team at iris in the health
department and I have the great pleasure
of working with everybody up here and as
has been mentioned we have such a great
partnership between iris and the folks
at Yale who run the refugee clinic and I
do believe we're pretty unique in the
country
as far as refugee resettlements having
such a partnership with the hospital
like that so that being said to talk
about the co-sponsor groups as was
mentioned also in irises effort back in
2015 to double the numbers of refugees
that we resettled largely in spawn in
response to the Syrian crisis the
worldwide crisis we turn to the
co-sponsorship model which is also
pretty unique in the country canada
certainly does it but connecticut is
unique in that we had such an outpouring
of support from individuals and groups
that contacted IRS to say hey what can
we do so we turn to the co-sponsors and
therefore we're able to double our
numbers so co-sponsor groups act like a
mini iris we get only one day of
intensive training for the
representatives of the group and each
department goes over on the aspects that
they should know to successfully
resettle their families so with health
we get about an hour and a half between
health and mental health issues woefully
inadequate um and your feedback on both
Jeanne and Carol is very important and
we certainly do hope to take what we've
learned so far and have some type of
workshops things like that
and very fortunately a group that cavae
is overseeing of NPH students recently
came to iris and said hey we'd love to
do some research what can we do so this
group are going to be looking into
mental health resources throughout the
state on based on experiences that were
brought up that we've had I'm noticing
that it's just super tough to find
mental health providers for anyone let
alone those that provide interpreters
accept Medicaid are accepting new
patients and have any level of cultural
competency dealing with clients from the
countries that we deal with so we're
looking into that we also have another
group that's also
doing some form of research based on the
co-sponsorship group from the past year
lessons learned and how to strengthen
that so yes its we couldn't have done it
without you so thank you and yeah I
think that's good
um 10:30 you have a well deserved coffee
break coming up so I want to just thank
the panelists again for three wonderful
presentation
[Music]